we find the girl and if she's the great
alpha she'll tell us where the moonstone
is hid in the caste of zombies welcome
tons of new actors to their set but did
you know that Milo Manheim was friends
with one of the werewolves before
zombies 2 was ever announced keep
watching to find out which werewolf was
trained in martial arts and became a
black belt at just 13 years old and
watch until the end to find out which
new star was severely bullied before
being welcomed into the Disney Channel
family why are you smiling because when
you said no I thought you didn't like me
anymore but the only problem here is a
bunch of bloodthirsty werewolves
Chandler Kinney stole the show as the
werewolf leader Willa she did such an
amazing job at playing the mature and
fierce werewolf it's hard to believe
that Chandler had just turned 19 years
old when she began filming the zombies
sequel it probably isn't your first time
seeing Chandler on the small screen
after all she has been acting since 2012
Chandler had small roles in Disney shows
like KC undercover and Girl Meets World
but besides that she appeared on TV
shows like Gordimer Gibbons life on
normal Street and The Haunted Hathaways
Chandler has been groomed for the
limelight ever since she was a little
kid at just 10 years old she was trained
in martial arts and received a black
belt by the age of 13 on top of that
Chandler is a professional dancer who
was given scholarships to three
different prestigious ballet schools
Chandler has been working around the
clock since she was nine years old which
is probably why she comes off as wise
beyond her years I only said flexing
Chow or
Aloha this ambiance just wouldn't be the
same without everyone's favorite zombie
boy said Zed is played by the talented
triple-threat milo Manheim who couldn't
wait to reprise his role for the sequels
despite being a popular actor Milo goes
to school like most eighteen year olds
he graduated high school in 2019 and
made sure to keep his green zombie hair
for the occasion after high school Milo
attended New York University where he's
now a drama major at the Tisch School of
Arts but attending NYU meant that Milo
had to leave one of his closest friends
behind for about a year Milo and his
best friend Mason Turner had their
YouTube channel called Milo and Mason
the creative duo posted videos of them
singing carpool karaoke segments they
also filmed and uploaded vlogs and
reaction videos when Milo landed the
role of said he had to put the channel
on hold to film in Toronto although they
haven't uploaded anything since February
of 2019 the duo will be up and added
again pretty soon Mason is all set to
join his best friend at NYU and will get
to hear all about their adventures on
Milo and Mason there's no one more
excited about today
Kingston Foster plays Ed's little sister
Zoey in zombies 1 & 2 she was the
youngest cast member on the set of the
film however the cast was so welcoming
that they never let her feel like the
odd one out during an interview with
17-mile owen kingston talked about their
zombie family and how it was missing a
core member a lot of viewers have
noticed that said and Zoe's mother is
nowhere to be found
what's worse is that she's never even
mentioned throughout the franchise fans
were hoping to hear about their mom in
zombies too but that never happened
Milo confessed that this missing link
has been talked about more than a few
times on set the actors want to know
what happened to Zed and Zoe's mom Zoe
is still young so there's no way that
Zedd wouldn't be able to remember their
mom according to Milo if Disney does
indeed move forward with a third and
final zombies installment Zed and Zoe's
mom should be a part of the plot
ever since Milo was a kid he dreamed of
becoming an actor just like his mom
Camryn Manheim and in 2009 when he was
just 8 years old he got a start on his
mother's show Ghost Whisperer Milo would
not be cast in another film until he
made waves as then but that's not to say
that he gave up on acting all together
instead Milo focused on musical theater
which was his passion
before zombies came to be my Louis cast
in the theater production of rent and
it's here that he caught a casting
agents eye his performance was so strong
that the casting agent approached him
after the show to see if he'd consider
auditioning for the upcoming Disney
Channel movie and well the rest is
pretty much history
Milo told 17 that he was a bit skeptical
at first
but that it ended up working out pretty
well and we have the mystery casting
agent to think for that I'm Sam and yeah
I'm a zombie it's hard to believe that
Pierce is only 17 years old the actor
already has an impressive acting
portfolio and he's just getting started
Pierce first started acting in 2014 and
just two years later he would appear in
three episodes of lab rats that same
year Pierce was cast as Logan in the TV
series legendary do does and from 2016
to 2020 Pierce portrayed spider Johnson
on mecha x4 clearly Pierce doesn't lack
any experience which is why casting him
as Wyatt in zombies 2 was a no brainer
for Disney Channel executives according
to sweetie hi Pierce has always looked
up to actor Jim Carrey
he grew up watching hilarious movies and
even imitated his comedy routines
however when Pierce watched Jim Carrey
in the movie Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind he was stunned by how
versatile the actor could be Pierce
revealed that this is the movie that had
the biggest impact on his determination
to becoming a professional actor you are
a leader Addison but if something a lot
greater than Shearer
you might be surprised to find out that
Trevor's side hustle is acting that's
right acting is just something Trevor
does for fun but his true passion is
dance and choreography Trevor is one of
the oldest cast members at 24 years old
he's a Canadian star who began acting in
2015 but despite starring in a handful
of movies and shows Trevor much prefers
to label himself as a choreographer
Trevor played James in the TV series the
next step where he served as an
assistant choreographer according to the
star the only thing he can't live
without is his music apps
Trevor revealed that he needs music in
his life because he's a dancer and a
choreographer suddenly we understand why
Trevor was such a perfect match for his
character Bucky they're both
perfectionists who put together
intricate performances and they'll stop
at nothing to win first place but
despite being gifted with two right feet
Trevor says that his voice could use
some work
but we still consider him a triple
threat great news we have a brilliant
and cheer tested candidate running for
president this year
Milo Manheim is a star through and
through not only does he have acting
singing and dancing in the bag but he's
also a musically talented individual who
plays a total of five instruments Milo
told 17 that he plays the guitar the
piano the drums and the ukulele and he
also revealed that he dabbles in the
horns too
Milo was encouraged to learn how to play
musical instruments when he was just a
kid
his mom signed him up for piano lessons
which he's super grateful for but as he
got older Milo took a liking to guitar
and got to work on learning the song
good riddance by Green Day
Milo loves the fact that he can bring
his guitar with him everywhere he goes
which wasn't the case for the piano
according to the actor music is his
therapy he would love to write his own
music however he admitted that he isn't
that good at it Milo we don't believe
that for a second that's true that's
true 19 year old macdonna Lee plays the
brave and accepting Addison in the
zombies franchise now we all know that
Megan Milo share a very special bond but
did you know that Meg also has a special
connection to
Briella from the High School Musical
franchise that's right Meg fell in love
with musical theater while watching
these Disney Channel movies she wanted
nothing more than to be like Gabriella
which is why Vanessa Hudgens is such a
big inspiration to her during an
interview with j14 magazine meg revealed
that she had to audition for the role of
Addison six different times
whereas Milo had to audition 13
different times to play Zedd during this
interview meg said that she related to
Addison in more ways than one but most
of all they share a special bond because
they're both optimistic leaders who love
to be around other people most likely
because they grew up without siblings
meg says that playing Addison has taught
her to be brave in everyday life but not
people here hate anything
this may come as a surprise but Milo and
baby Arielle didn't meet for the first
time while on this set of zombies - as a
matter of fact they met a year before
the sequel was even in the works
although bibi Arielle's character winter
doesn't always get along with that in
the movie Milo and baby Arielle are
super close in real life believe it or
not but they met while on the plane they
both already knew about each other due
to social media and they immediately
bonded Milo and Arielle posted about
their meeting and fans went wild
Milo revealed that their meeting and all
the buzz it created online had an impact
on Arielle being chosen to play winter
we're going after the moonstone top
secret you can't tell anyone
baby Arielle whose real name is Arielle
Martin landed her first acting gig when
she was just 15 years old but back then
life wasn't easy for the rising star
like many Disney stars Arielle was
bullied when she was a kid what's worse
is that she didn't know why she was
being bullied
luckily for Arielle she received a lot
of love from her family and friends
which made it a lot easier for her to
handle the heat did you know that
Arielle became a social media star
before she ever appeared on TV in 2015
Arielle downloaded the app musically and
made an account and before she knew it
she had tons of followers today Arielle
has over 3 million subscribers on
YouTube and a whopping 9 million
followers on Instagram Arielle is
working on both her acting and music
career and already has a handful of
music videos out on her channel and
that's a wrap on the 10 things you
didn't know about the cast of zombies -
before you go tell us which new song was
your favorite in the comments below
thanks for watching the things for more
fun content be sure to LIKE and
subscribe we'll see you next time
you